so when are we finally going to see a
militia reboot okay we see all these
reboots and i was such a militia fan
when is this happening you know what
it's it's we're still talking about it i
i'm so open for it i want it so badly
and i think just the way the show ended
it ended on a cliffhanger and i think
you know the people that have supported
militia over the years they they want
they want answers and
i feel like it would be so appropriate
to do one and
and i just want everybody that's
watching i'm with it i really want to do
it
so is is there a a young singer actress
you could see
starring in this like taking on your
part in moisha
i don't want to give my part up i want
to do the reboot
i love it i love it i didn't know if
you'd read it different way you know
people keep rebooting
in a different way and they almost take
like a different role like somebody else
comes up i didn't know how you all would
do that but
that's cool you're like me you like a
lot of jobs
i love i love to i love acting and i
would just i'd love to just tell that
story and see how far i could go
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel
please don't make me keep going